leute mein erster schuss ich würde sagen
ich treffe so fort
wer etwas glaubt herzlich willkommen
beim nur ein video
ja ich habe heute noch mal kurz rein
mein bruder wieder mit dabei und zwar
haben wir uns heute was ganz besonderes
überlegt
ja wir sind hier im garten man sieht
schon wir haben hier einige änderungen
vorgenommen und zwar gibt es heute von
uns eine fussball challenge aber nicht
eine ganz normale fußball challenge
sondern ganz einfach fußball challenge
extrem wie schon gesagt haben den ast ab
gebunden da hinten sind zwei mülltonnen
erste challenge gleich sein du kannst ja
einmal auf die mit anzeigen
da sind die mülltonne da ist ein dach
wir gehen jetzt gleichauf dieses dach
hoch und versuchen dann von da oben die
mülltonnen zu treffen nächste challenge
wird sein wir werden in unser haus
schießen in der art und die dritte
challenge seht ihr dann mal gucken wer
gewinnt bestrafung zu schießen okay ich
hab das jetzt schon mal mit den lobbys
gemacht das war auf jeden fall witzig
ich würde sagen wir fangen an let's go
so leute wir sind jetzt hier auf dem
dach könnte vielleicht das ein oder
andere mal etwas laut werden weil da ist
die straße aber da vorne sind die beiden
mülltonnen kannst du einmal draußen
du fängst an alles kann natürlich sagen
hier ist dabei bitteschön so leute es
geht jetzt hier um wer jetzt erste
single von trifft verteilt gewarnt also
egal wie viele versuche ich würde sagen
jetzt kommt der wind heute mein erster
schluss ich würde sagen den ball hat man
gar nicht mehr gesehen dass wir irgendwo
daneben
das netz sei so schwer kann das so
eigentlich gar nicht sein oder passt
auch der geht jetzt rein ja nur ihn
irgendwo ins rosenweg
das kann er noch nicht sagen ja
na ja oder nein
letzte war einst dürfen nicht mag wird
irgendwas zu dem schluss sagen ja ich
treffe noch mal ja eh nicht kommt ja
leute der erste punkt geht ganz klar in
ihnen herzlichen glückwunsch einzel für
dich nächste challenge wir müssen jetzt
da oben in mein zimmer rein schießen
von da hinten jeder hat einfach drei
versuche wer von drei versuchen mehr
trifft hat gewonnen und
nur war eng
es wird sagen trifft
also leute dritte runde wird muss ich
auch schaffen wenn ich treffe den ball
holen
okay leute es steht jetzt 1 1 aber wir
haben für die erste challenge wirklich
so lange gebraucht lockt eine stunde
oder so weil wir einfach diesen scheiß
diese scheiß mülltonnen nicht getroffen
haben deswegen haben uns gedacht wir
machen jetzt einfach schön club und der
gewinner hat gewonnen weil ich muss
gleich weg und als rallye
es kann doch so ein traktor
bis 31 bis 111 leute schnick schnack
schnuck das heißt jetzt schießen dreimal
für ok hier leute ja ich muss jetzt die
bestrafung machen das heißt erschießen
kennt wahrscheinlich jeder von euch hier
bitte bist du das ding ist der schuss
von ihnen ihr wart ein
ich merke das gar nicht durch noch mal
leute das war's mit dem video
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann lasst
einfach mal jetzt nach oben da würde
mich sehr freuen jetzt kommt irgendein
auto wieder ansonsten hier ist ein
instagram einbringen können sie mir
gerne weil folgen
wir sehen uns dann hat rice